Transcriptor: Emma Gon
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Cada vez que entro a Instagram, veo
lugares a los cuales no voy a poder ir.
Familias que no se pelean.
Comidas que nunca salen mal.
Cuerpos que no voy a poder tener.
Veo un mundo perfecto.
Y con cada foto que aparece,
empieza a crecer en mí
un sentimiento de tristeza.
Cuando estoy a punto de cerrar la app,
veo que una influencer
sube una foto de sí misma,
llorando,
también perfecta,
como si fuese un modelo de llanto.
Cuando dejo el celular,
hago lo que cualquier filósofo haría,
ir a charlar con Platón.
Este filósofo es famoso por
haber creado la teoría de las ideas.
En esta teoría, que aparece en su diálogo
La República, él propone
que para cada cosa
que existe en este mundo
hay una versión, un modelo,
más propiamente una idea,
que habita en otro plano.
Por ejemplo, la idea de árbol,
cuando uno piensa en un árbol
la idea de árbol, no piensa
ni en este ni en aquel árbol.
Piense en un paradigma, un modelo
de árbol, el árbol perfecto.
Y solamente conociendo ese paradigma
podemos juzgar qué cosas son más árbol
y menos árbol en este mundo.
Por ejemplo, si yo tengo
una pintura, un jacarandá,
eso es menos árbol,
está más lejos de la idea de árbol
que un jacarandá de verdad,
porque el jacarandá de verdad
es más árbol que una pintura.
Y así con todas las cosas.
La idea más importante, la que regía
todas las demás, era la idea de bien.
Y solamente conociendo
esa idea podemos juzgar
qué cosas son mejores
y peores en este mundo.
Un buen hombre, un modelo de hombre.
Los modelos.
Las modelos, ¿acaso Platón
sembró la idea para una app
que por cada cosa
que existe en este mundo,
nos muestra su versión ideal?
¿Acaso Platón podría decirse,
creó Instagram?
En La República, basado
en su teoría de las ideas,
Platón construye un proyecto político.
Nos propone una ciudad
perfectamente virtuosa
que tenemos que usar como modelo a seguir.
Pero no se quedó ahí Platón, no,
viajó de Atenas, su ciudad natal,
a Sicilia
para hacer realidad este proyecto.
Invitado por un político de la época,
Dionisio fue como su asesor,
zarpó hacia Sicilia.
La aventura no le salió muy bien.
Cuando llegó a Sicilia, Dionisio estaba
muy poco interesado en la filosofía
y demasiado interesado en
verse rodeado de intelectuales.
Y esto a Platón no le gustó nada.
Se pelearon.
Dionisio se niega a ser justo, escribe
Platón en una de las cartas, más tarde.
Se intentó ir, un pequeño forcejeo
negociaciones, hubo fuerza bruta incluida,
pero después de idas y vueltas, Dionisio
lo dejó volver a Atenas, a Platón.
Y con la experiencia de este fracaso,
Platón escribió un nuevo diálogo,
mucho más oscuro,
mucho más extenso que La República.
Un diálogo que los especialistas
dicen que es un Platón pesimista.
Un diálogo oscuro de
12 libros llamado Leyes.
Durante mi doctorado, hace unos años,
me propuse leer este texto bien de cerca.
Tenía la sospecha de que iba a
poder responder una pregunta clave:
¿Por qué no nos sirven los ideales?
Así que agarré, puse el texto griego
en el centro de la mesa
el castellano a la derecha,
el inglés a la izquierda
y así avancé párrafo
a párrafo, línea a línea.
Cuando terminé, seguí la misma
conclusión que los otros especialistas.
Platón,
pareciera haber perdido la confianza en
la capacidad humana para ser mejores.
Platón sonaba pesimista.
El diálogo Leyes queda inconcluso,
porque Platón se murió
mientras lo escribía.
Y siempre me imaginé a Platón
muriendo de amargura,
porque al fin y al cabo había dedicado
su vida entera a hacernos mejores.
Pero un párrafo de Leyes, 10,
me ha quedado dando vueltas en la cabeza,
un párrafo difícil.
En ese párrafo, Platón describe
el movimiento del universo
y dice que el alma del  cosmos
es perfectamente buena
y gira sobre sí misma, y en ese giro
mueve a todas
las demás almas  corporeizadas
que son dependientes,
débiles y corruptibles.
Y me quedé pensando.
Un alma perfecta,
rodeada de almas imperfectas
y corporeizadas,
¿no será esa la razón por la cual Platón
perdió la confianza en los humanos?
Porque claro, nunca vamos a poder ser
perfectos como el alma cósmica universal.
No podemos.
Nuestra propia naturaleza humana
de cuerpo y alma nos lo impide.
Y ahí el texto de Leyes
cobró otro sentido, otro color,
porque todo lo que yo antes leía
como propuestas pesimistas,
un Platón que había perdido la confianza,
de repente se volvían propuestas prácticas
para una naturaleza humana débil.
Por ejemplo, nos propone
Platón que usemos
la herramienta de la auto
examinación para mejorarnos.
No tiene sentido estar
todo el tiempo comparándose
con aquella persona, esta persona,
nadie es perfecto,
no podemos serlo.
Entonces, la mejor técnica
es verse hacia atrás
y asegurarse de que la versión
de hoy de nuestro ser
nuestro carácter,
es mejor que la anterior.
Estamos todos rotos,
no hay modelos,
pero sí podemos focalizarnos
en auto repararnos todo el tiempo.
Otro ejemplo, las emociones.
En diálogos anteriores, Platón había
querido controlar las emociones;
quería a veces acallarlas,
mantenerlas bien agarradas.
En Leyes se relaja al respecto.
No podemos hacer nada.
Las emociones son parte de nuestra vida.
Entonces, si somos
seres irritables, nos dice,
no acallemos eso,
usemos la energía del enojo
para motivar proyectos positivos.
Porque no tiene sentido pelearse
con nuestra naturaleza irritable.
No tiene sentido.
Sí, puede ser que la teoría de las ideas
haya sido el primer paso hacia Instagram.
Pero yo creo que Platón
nos dio una herramienta
para romper con Instagram también.
Porque allá afuera no hay modelos,
nadie es perfecto.
No podemos serlo, no podemos.
Todos nacemos con un alma débil,
pero esa debilidad nos libera
de la presión de la perfección.
Porque con la perfección
no se construye ninguna república
ni se construye ninguna persona.
Y sí podemos asegurarnos a cada momento
de ser mejores que ayer.
No, no creo que Platón
se haya muerto pesimista,
no, para mí se murió optimista.
Porque si encontramos el placer
en las pequeñas mejoras diarias,
tenemos todo por ganar.
No importan los modelos, no importan,
y nos liberamos todos juntos
de la pesadilla de la perfección.